and here we are up early on our second
hour of YouTube videos hey everybody I'm
Hannah and I'm trying to be a better mom
and if you're a working parent like me
you understand that weekends with kids
are precious commodities it is very
precious time and for me as a working
parent with a working spouse what I've
noticed is what we end up doing on the
weekends is I plan the entire what I've
noticed happens on the weekends is I end
up planning everything and what I end up
planning is basically cramming in all
the errands that I couldn't run during
the week into the weekend with my kids
and now that my kids are a little bit
older and a little bit more vocal about
their wants and needs I'm starting to
realize that they look forward all week
to the weekend and having that quality
time with their parents and the way that
I've been planning the weekends is not
spending quality time together
so I want to try something I want to
have my kids plan an entire weekend for
us and I want to do this because first
of all I just want to see what
activities they're interested in that we
can implement into future weekends and
second I want to see what their ideal
weekend looks like let's try it so we're
gonna start this weekend on Friday night
because let's be real the weekend starts
Friday pretty much after work in school
right so what are we gonna do tonight
guys where are we gonna go eat
so the first thing they asked Friday
night is to go to the restaurant with
the tomato on the sign it was like
totally poppin on a Friday night there
was a 45-minute wait to get a table but
let me tell you it was so worth it that
salad man like salad on salad on salad I
was so happy my kids were stoked they
have a soft-serve machine this is not a
plug for soup plantation I swear I was
just so happy with it you know it's like
something so simple and tiny is trying
out a new restaurant that's kind of
unique and something they know they've
never tried before but they were really
grateful for it so we didn't have much
time after to do much of anything that
evening so the kids requested that we
rent a movie at home and have family
movie night on the couch which was just
so pure
we watched neverending story why it fell
asleep on my chest it was like the
perfect night so far so good
so Saturday morning we wake up and it is
just gnarly like my kids are being
buckets it was one of those mornings and
I don't know if any of you guys out
there have experienced this with your
kids wake up and just everything you say
is wrong like Wyatt asked for a waffle
for breakfast I got him a waffle he
asked for some whipped cream on it I put
some whipped cream on he drops the floor
shrieking because I put the whipped
cream on that he asked for made me wipe
it off then put the whipped cream back
on and it was just like oh my god eat
your waffle or don't get anything I'm so
over this so I actually decided to put
this little test on pause for the first
half of Saturday until my kids could get
their act together any other parent who
disciplines their kids will understand
that it it's a really guilty feeling
when I have to cancel stuff or take
things away from them but ultimately
it's what they needed in the moment to
realize that that behavior is not
acceptable so Saturday second half of a
Saturday they first asked if they could
go to the park
and I actually took that time to go and
play with them on the play equipment I
looked pretty weird and awkward I
noticed that I tend to kind of like
stand back and watch them play but I
really wanted to take this time to be
involved with them it was so much fun
they got out all this pent-up energy
that I think maybe had been the cause of
earlier that day so after the park my
kids were literally full of wood chips
in every crevice of their body that we
needed to do bath time
on the way home Wyatt my fancy boy he's
literally the fanciest child I've ever
met he is like a rich 90 year old woman
in a little baby's body he asked for a
spa night he wanted to go pick up bath
balm lotion where his bathrobe do all
that stuff and just be very fancy that
night my kids are so weird the one
compromise I had to make was he is
obsessed with lush and lush bath bombs
but I don't think you realize is that
mom doesn't have that kind of flow to
get $8 baths every day so we ended up
compromising and going to Target and
putting a big pack of mini bath bombs
and so it actually worked out perfectly
because each kid could hold their own
bath bomb and physically it's always
this huge fight over who gets to hold
the bath bomb for what amount of time
when it's fizzling we did the bath we
did the rose we did the lotion it was
very very fancy they said that their
bath smell delicious and they were
actually excited to be in the bath and
be clean for once which was much
appreciated so while Saturday started
out being a total fiasco it actually
ended up being amazing and fun and I was
really looking forward to Sunday
so Sunday final day I knew exactly what
was coming on Sunday because it's
something my kids asked for constantly
and I knew they were going to ask and
they delivered they asked to spend the
day at my parents house so my kids
really wanted to bring their costumes to
my parents house to show my sister
Stella because this year halloween fell
on a Tuesday and so they weren't gonna
be able to spend time with her that day
and she wouldn't be able to see their
costumes live and in person which is
apparently very important when you're
five years old in two years old so we
packed their costumes got in the car
they asked just up for brunch okay we're
here at brunch and I feel very awkward
vlogging right now I don't know if this
is me rubbing off on my kids or if my
kids are just bougie as heck because
what five-year-old kid asks for brunch
like what five-year-old can't even knows
what brunch is I don't know where that
came from so we are here at my parents
house right now and for weeks and weeks
and weeks leading up to Halloween which
is this coming week Jax has been begging
to go trick-or-treating with my family
but the issue is on Halloween Matt and I
both work and by the time we're off work
at home it's too late for us to drive
all the way to my parents house so he
asked while we're here if you can go
trick-or-treating with my family and I
don't exactly know how we're gonna pull
this off but I'm sure it's not gonna try
so we get all their costumes we go out
and we just start ringing on doorbells
and everyone's reaction is kind of like
[Music]
all of their neighbors went rummaging
for whatever they could find in their
pantries cabinets whatever they could
find to give my kids in their Halloween
buckets and so my kids ended up with
loot bags full of the weirdest I've ever
seen in my life
and they were so grateful for it it was
so cute every time Jackson would get
something new in his basket he'd be like
I'm not having this on Monday and it was
just it was so precious so I actually
ended up when they're going through like
trading their candy and like trying to
trade a can of lentils for a can of
Olives I actually went and I got some
candy for them it just encompassed
everything I love about my kids they're
weird
they're funny they're out they're
totally out there and even though they
can be little butt heads sometimes at
the end of the day they're just they're
very genuinely sweet kids so if you want
to try this I would highly recommend it
if it was awesome for us and if you want
to you know trust your kids and let go
of the reins a little bit I would highly
recommend it not only will you learn
that there are more fun ways to spend
quality time together
I think it'll help you realize just how
sweet your kids can be because that's a
it for me that's I got for today I'm
Hannah a semi ok cool mom and if you try
this experiment leave a comment and let
me know how it went or you can always
text me this is a real number I do read
every single text but I don't
necessarily respond because I do get a
lot of them and if you guys have an idea
for something for me to try in a future
episode leave that in the comments too
and if you'll please excuse me I
literally got no errands done this
weekend my refrigerator has no food in
it and I need to go to the grocery store
stat til next time
[Music]